♪ ♪ ♪
-Ça fait des années qu'on a
des blablabla, c'est tout.
- Donnez-moi ma chance
et on verra.
- La désillusion des électeurs
ne décourage pas le candidat
bloquiste Simon Marchand.
- Je vais tout faire pour que
ça se fasse.
- C'est la 3e fois qu'il se
présente dans la circonscription
d'Hochelaga.
En 2019, il a perdu par environ
300 voix contre la candidate
libérale.
SIMON MARCHAND, candidat Bloc
Qc. circonscription Hochelaga
- Dès le lendemain, quand
on parlait aux gens dans
la rue, ils disaient : "Ouais,
j'étais tellement sûr que ça
allait être le Bloc, je suis
juste pas allé voter".
Donc cette année, quand on
parle aux gens qui disent cette
année, j'ai laissé que c'est
important, j'y serai,
je comprends que chaque vote
dans l'urne.
- Et il peut compter sur celui
d'Henri Tremblay.
- J'ai toujours pas mal voté
Bloc. Et puis en toute
franchise, s'il ne m'avait pas
parlé cette année des logements,
j'aurais pas voté Bloc
cette année à cause justement
du chef.
- À 62 ans, ça fait maintenant
7 ans qu'il attend un logement
abordable.
- Y'a des HLM qui sont fermés
ici ça fait 3 ans. Il y a
personne qui les habite, ils ne
sont pas rénovés. Tout ce qu'il
a à faire le gouverment, c'est
de les rénover puis de
les distribuer aux gens.
Il y a des gens qui attendent.
♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est aussi le sujet
des habitués de la rue Ontario
avec leurs emblématiques
triporteurs.
- Les logements ils coûtent
tellement chers, ça prend
des HLM, des coops pis toute,
hein? C'est ça que ça prend?
Pas des affaires de même, là!
- Pas de condos dit-il.
Depuis quelques années,
l'embourgeoisement a créé
de nouveaux défis pour
les organismes communautaires.
EVE CYR, présidente La Table
de Quartier, Hochelaga
- On a beaucoup de jeunes
familles, de jeunes
professionnels, mais on a aussi
des jeunes familles
en difficulté. On le voit par
exemple dans les écoles où on a
perdu certaines mesures
alimentaires parce que
les indices de défavorisation
se transformaient à cause
de justement la création, par
exemple, d'une tour à condo dans
un secteur défavorisé.
- L'anxiété du logement,
je la comprends.
- La députée libérale sortante
défend son bilan.
SORAYA MARTINEZ FERRADA,
candidate libérale, Hochelaga
- On a livré une allocation
au logement qui n'existait pas.
Ici, dans Hochelaga, on a rénové
de HLM qui étaient, écoute, en
décrépitude depuis plus de 30
ans. Sincèrement, j'ai plus fait
en 18 mois que l'ancienne
députée en 8 ans.
- Pas assez pour Philippe Grohe,
québécois anglophone, son vote
ira à l'environnement.
- C'est un problème puis j'ai
une petite-fille ici qui...
tu sais, je veux quand même
qu'elle aille une qualité
de vie.
-Ça vous rend émotif
on dirait, oui.
- Déçu des libéraux, il songe
à voter pour le NPD.
- Je fais signer une pétition
sur les changements climatiques.
- Envoyez fort!
- La candidate néodémocrate fait
beaucoup campagne sur ce point.
CATHERYN ROY-GOYETTE, candidate
NPD, circonscription Hochelaga
- Dans Hochelaga, au niveau
environnement, bien, on a
un enjeu très concret, qui
est le dossier de
Ray Mont Logistique.
- Ray Mont logistique,
c'est un projet de plateforme
de transbordement pour
accueillir environ
10 000 conteneurs sur
ce terrain contaminé.
C'est devenu le projet
de la discorde contre lequel
les citoyens sont mobilisés.
- Ce projet-là implique
du bruit, un îlot chaleur
immense. On parle d'à peu près
46 terrains de football
asphaltés.
- Pour plusieurs d'entres eux,
c'est l'enjeu numéro 1 et
le choix est difficile puisque
les trois candidats se sont
positionnés contre le projet.
- Il faut que les bottines
suivent les babines. Donc on
verra...  Je sais pas qui
a vraiment le pouvoir d'agir
parce que c'est quand même...
il y a des enjeux qui sont très
fédéraux aussi, on ne se
le cachera pas avec le port
et tout, le CN.
- Mon choix n'est pas fait,
mais en même temps, on ne veut
pas diviser les votes.
Fait que c'est politique
finalement, c'est pas facile.
- Avec un électorat volatile
qui a changé d'allégeance 3 fois
en 10 ans, la course ici
se jouera à trois
jusqu'à la fin.
Ici Jacaudrey Charbonneau,
Radio-Canada, dans
la circonscription d'Hoch